well hi this is Adam Smith calling from
nobelprize.org the website of the Nobel
Prize in Stockholm well first of all
congratulations on the award of the
Prize in Economic Sciences thank you may
I ask how the news reached you woke me
up nice way to be working um people will
perhaps best know you feel Book nudge
published almost a decade ago for those
of you who don't know could you just
describe what a nudge is not just some
feature of the environment that changes
the behavior of humans but would not
change the behavior of rational economic
agents what we call econ so for example
the research I was talking about in
Stockholm a couple of weeks ago was
about two nudges in the Swedish pension
system one was creating a default fund
that people would take if they didn't
make a choice and then the other was a
advertising campaign encouraging people
not to take physical and the paper that
we're now writing is sort of a battle of
those who write yes what's your favorite
example of a successful nudge well you
know I would say probably the most
successful has been the use of what we
call automatic enrollment in pension
plans meaning the default is to join
rather than not to join right for
example this has been used in a recent
rollout of the national pension savings
plan in the UK and the enrolment rates
are well over 90 percent it's 15 years
since your friend Daniel Kahneman was
awarded the prize I
I suppose since then what we've seen is
a absolute blossoming of the field of
behavioral economics has it reached a
point do you think where it can be used
for making tools for setting public
policy well sure I mean
that's what somebody asked me to come
over to Stockholm to talk about three
weeks ago and I think our research has
greatly changed pension systems all
around the world the idea of saved more
tomorrow where you invite people to
commit themselves to saving more
sometime in the future has been quite
successful you think there may be as
many as 25 million people in the u.s.
involved in that program countries all
around the world starting with the UK of
started behavioural insights often
referred to as nudge unit and they
shouldn't be doing lots of good just the
last thing we all like to think we're
different don't we but somehow your work
of course brings us all into a unifying
theory is there a kind of disparity
there between people's individual belief
in their own individuality and oh sure
people are different the key findings
from Kahneman and Tversky the research
it's not that everybody is the same but
that on average we tend to err in the
same direction so we all think that
we're gonna finish project then we will
although some people procrastinate more
than others yeah I think that describes
me yeah and and my home contractor at
the moment you sound very calm how do
you feel well not master of
understatement
we'll we look forward to welcoming you
to Stockholm December yes I had the
pleasure of coming with professor
Kahneman and he keeps telling me I
better win it soon because he wants to
go back so
it'll be a pleasure to ask him to join
me again oh that's gorgeous and you will
reverse roles whoa see it from different
perspective okay well we very much look
forward to having you here once again
congratulations thank you thank you for
speaking to me